you had a second date yet no [ __ ]  call him back  no I attacked you last night so you're  gonna have a second date she comes into  my she's like guess why FaceTime last  we're rootin for you we're invest in our  what you can get wicked we make the  second date happen I need to know what  if you put amine on number one week so I  can hey no no because you make me black  fries is the Goodbody ghost is now in  our DNA we need to know who the Goodbody  ghost is and know if it's going well and  all this week we going well so far but I  won't get any more details away all  right we're leaving alone are you  leaving alone are you making sure I have  tea I'm like the big brother now so like  she updates me and I'm like this is okay  this is definitely not okay but it's all  okay so please I miss wheet hi I'm ready  for my Zelda  you